is eating in bed gross
no eating in bed is okay it's licking
the pillow that's gross what if you
let's say let's say this one how about
this I was just a hypothetical no he's
gonna ask me a question this is
hypothetical like every one of these has
not been
this one's hypothetical I've been
dealing with reality up until this
you've you fall asleep in bed right
you're you're you want to sleep and you
read tons of candy you had like sour
patch kids everywhere and eat a couple
melted Reese's is it gross to eat those
like after you kind of roll around on
them no then they're all soft and warm I
like to when the food when the food is
in the bed and then after a whole night
of pressing you know it's like a human
Panini yeah I I know that's what it is
you're joking but I love it yeah human
Panini you know what a panini is where
you put it in the thing and it what if
you did that with your body you wouldn't
eat it I just flattened this
and it's Sour Patch Kids is your choice
for bed